Good morning John,
I'm about to sing you a song,
but first I have
a couple of things to tell you.
First: my hands are kinda permanently red.
And you'll find out why later.
Second: mostly, I want to say thank you
to everyone who helped me out with this.
There are a lot of different parts in this
song,
but I can't play any of them,
so I had Nerdfighters do it for me.
So, thank you to Paige, Derling,
Danielle, Elisiah, Morgan and Kevin
for all of your amazing Irish fiddling
and penny whistle playing.
I'm sorry I couldn't use everybody's;
there were some problems with sound
and with actually getting the video
to work in my computer,
so I just used what I could use.
Thank you to all of you;
you did an amazing job.
Lastly, before I share this song,
I want to talk a little bit about squirrel
linguistics.
You may or may not know this,
but squirrels -
they speak.
[Imitating squirrel chattering]
Cruchla crcruchler chrr crurlarr -
little squirrel noises.
But, in addition:
the way that we have, like,
eyebrow movements and, like, facial expressions,
they have tail movements,
and the tail movements are extremely important
in squirrel talking.
And squirrels, though you may not know this,
have names.
And each name consists of a vocal component
and a tail movement.
And this song is about a squirrel
named Scuzzy Kizoozle ... Curl.
[Irish fiddling]
[Singing, with Irish accent]
Oh, there's a lot of ways to die,
Under Ireland's skies,
But the worst way, by far,
might be a bit of a surprise.
I'd rather be knifed in a bar,
or hit by a car,
Than to meet my end
lookin' into her eyes
And hear the cries
Of my demise,
My last goodbyes.
Oh, she's a six-ounce ball
of blood, muscle, and fur,
And she's the evilest thing
in this or any world.
And you better start a-runnin'
if you ever see her;
She's Scuzzy Kizoozle Curl,
The homicidal squirrel.
Well, I was at the county fair,
and Scuzzy Kizoozle was there.
She was slicing through the crowd,
like a mower mowin' lawns.
I watched the people fall
to her razor sharp claws,
And then she was right there in my face,
before I knew what was goin' on.
I raised my arm,
And tried to run,
But I was stunned!
Well, she's a six-ounce ball
of blood, muscle, and fur;
She's the evilest thing
in this or any world.
And you better start a-runnin',
if you ever see her;
She's Scuzzy Kizoozle Curl,
The homicidal squirrel.
Well, her teeth sank into my arm, and
Everything but pain was gone, and I
looked down at
Her bloodstained fangs.
She looked into my eyes,
The fear war paralizin', I
felt the blood running from my veins.
And oh, the pain,
And oh, the pain!
Well, she's a six-ounce ball
of blood, muscle, and fur,
And she's the evilest thing
in this or any world.
And you better start a-runnin',
if you ever see her;
She's Scuzzy Kizoozle Curl,
The homicidal squirrel.
I'm only alive today
by God's grace
I'm the only man who's met with her
And lived to tell the tale.
But I keep my eyes wide;
She'll never be denied.
Until the day I die,
she'll be right there on my tail.
O'er hill or dale,
Through rain and hail,
She will prevail!
Well, she's a six-ounce ball
of blood, muscle, and fur,
And she's the evilest thing
in this or any world.
And you better start a-runnin'
if you ever see her,
She's Scuzzy Kizoozle Curl,
The homicidal squirrel.
John, I'll...
What is that?
Arhh, arhhhhh, arh, arhhh, arh!
[High-pitched maniacal laughter]